y
[Música]
el presidente de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador celebró que la suprema
corte de justicia ordenara que continúe
la consulta revocatoria el mandatario
promueve esa votación tenemos
información desde mexico
en ecuador será obligatoria la vacuna
contra el cob y 19 todos los mayores de
12 años deberán tener las dosis
aplicadas para poder entrar a
establecimientos públicos la única
opción es para quienes tengan
contraindicaciones clínicas comprobadas
enlazamos a quito
el presidente de rusia vladimir putin
exigió garantías de seguridad inmediatas
a la otan ya estados unidos sigue
reclamando que la alianza finalice su
expansión hacia el este y aseguró que la
respuesta rusa dependerá de occidente
buenas noches y bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 yo soy manejar a
calle iniciamos en méxico la suprema
corte de justicia ordenó continuar con
la consulta sobre la revocación del
mandato del presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador antes el instituto
nacional electoral el inem la desactivó
argumentando que no había presupuesto
para realizarla el mismo lópez obrador
impulso a la consulta revocatoria
prevista para abril esto fue lo que dijo
el mandatario luego de la sentencia con
una muy buena este decisión porque es la
democracia
este porque no se debe de obstaculizar
la democracia
y segundo no se debe violar la
constitución
son las dos cosas
y yo considero que oponerse a la
revocación del mandato
a que se celebre una consulta que se le
pregunta a los ciudadanos sobre el
comportamiento de una autoridad
sí sé
obstaculiza ese procedimiento
es
actuar de manera antidemocrática
previamente conversamos con nuestro
corresponsal mario carbonell quien está
en ciudad de méxico él nos explicó por
qué el tribunal avaló la consulta
revocatoria a pesar de que la autoridad
electoral decía que no tenía el dinero
hola bien pues el tribunal emitió este
fallo luego de que el presidente de la
cámara de diputados del partido morena
interpuso una controversia
constitucional precisamente contra este
acuerdo del ine del instituto nacional
electoral de posponer las etapas de
organización de la consulta las dos
ministras que están encargadas de la
comisión de receso durante este periodo
en el tribunal constitucional
consideraron que no es posible
restringir los derechos políticos de los
ciudadanos y además consideraron que el
presupuesto aún recortado el dinero que
asignó el ine para la consulta tiene una
viabilidad financiera para llevar a cabo
todas las etapas de organización de este
ejercicio ciudadano por lo que de manera
provisional pues determinaron que debes
seguir el ine ha respondido que acá está
el fallo pero que esperar a que se
resuelva de fondo la controversia que
ellos mismos pusieron los consejeros
contra el recorte presupuestal en eeuu
la ex policía a kimberley potter fue
declarada culpable de homicidio
involuntario en primer y segundo grado
por la muerte del afroamericano down
aquí le propinó un disparo mortal los
hechos ocurrieron el pasado 11 de abril
en la ciudad de brooklyn brooklyn center
cuando supuestamente potter intentó
aturdida el joven de 20 años con un
teaser pero lo confundió con su arma de
fuego la jueza regina chuck ordenó su
detención inmediata su sentencia se
conocerá el 18 de febrero y la ex
policía podría enfrentar hasta 15 años
de cárcel
ahora hagamos un repaso por las noticias
del cob y 19 en américa
empezamos en eeuu porque la autoridad
sanitaria efe de amd aprobó la pastilla
contra el cob y 19 que desarrolló la
farmacéutica merck ayer ya había dado
luz verde para una píldora similar del
laboratorio facer estos son los primeros
medicamentos orales para combatir el
coronavirus
y las islas caribeñas de curazao y aruba
impidieron el desembarco de un crucero
de la compañía royal caribbean que
partió desde florida y es que 55
pasajeros y miembros de la tripulación
del ady síntesis dieron positivo por
kobe 19 ahora el barco deberá seguir
navegando hasta que vuelva el domingo al
puerto estadounidense
y en ecuador la vacuna contra el kobe 19
ya será obligatoria para todos los
mayores de 12 años el ministerio de
salud toma una decisión ante el aumento
de casos y la circulación de variantes
como omicron el carné de vacunación será
necesario para entrar establecimientos
públicos todos los detalles los tiene
nuestro corresponsal en quito- gustavo
ortega
el gobierno ecuatoriano ha declarado
obligatoria la vacunación contra las 19
a través de un documento publicado en
las cuentas oficiales de ministerio de
salud y la secretaria de comunicación de
la presidencia se informar los
lineamientos que deberán acatar en los
ciudadanos de manera inmediata según la
justificación legal es la normativa de
salud y la constitución ecuatoriana
otorga la potestad al estado de declarar
la medida el documento no será
obligatorio para quienes presenten
condiciones médicas o contraindicaciones
certificadas ante el estado además
señala que las autoridades dijeran el
cumplimiento de esta nueva normativa
según la ley de salud en el país andino
el ministerio del ramo ha de declarar la
obligatoriedad de las inmunizaciones
contra determinadas enfermedades según
la realidad epidemiológica que presenta
el país la constitución de éste también
impone como deber los ecuatorianos
promover el bien común y el interés
general ante intereses particulares la
medida que se justifica en tres causales
anunciadas por el ejecutivo aumento del
caso positivo de la comey 19 inclusive
de la variante omicron en el país el
incremento de la tasa de fallecidos que
ha pasado de 11 a 23 decesos por semana
y los niveles de positividad de la
comida 19 según el documento oficial las
sanciones se aplicarán a todo comercio o
servicio no esencial que permita el
acceso a los ciudadanos sin presentar el
carné de vacunación
el presidente de estadounidense joe
biden firmó la nueva legislación que
prohíbe las importaciones desde xinjiang
la región semiautónoma de china la norma
presume que todos los bienes que se
producen allí son producto de la
explotación laboral en los campos de
detención donde está en la minoría
musulmana de los uigur en xinjiang es un
gran productor de algodón y suministra
buena parte de los elementos necesarios
para construir los paneles solares del
mundo china niega los abusos
el presidente ruso vladimir putin exigió
a eeuu y a la otan que ofrezcan
garantías inmediatas para la seguridad
de rusia el mandatario les advirtió que
podría empantanar las negociaciones que
están previstas para inicios del 2022
ante los temores de una eventual
invasión rusa a ucrania aunque el
kremlin afirma que no busca un conflicto
agregó que las acciones de rusia
dependerán de las garantías que reciba
por parte de occidente y exige que la
otan no expanda más su territorio
militar hasta el extendió oficiales de
washington se mostraron dispuestos a
mantener la diplomacia pero destacaron
que no apoyaran varias de las propuestas
de rusia y magistrados de diseñar
nuestras acciones dependerán no del
proceso de negociación y sino de la
seguridad incondicional de rusia tanto
hoy como en la perspectiva histórica con
respecto a esto hemos dejado claro y de
manera explícita que un mayor movimiento
de la otan hacia el este es inaceptable
y que no queda claro somos nosotros los
que ponemos misiles cerca de las
fronteras estadounidenses no es estados
unidos el que ha venido con sus misiles
hasta nuestra casa están en la puerta de
nuestra casa donde humana julio suyo y
el telescopio espacial james webb de la
nasa será lanzado finalmente después de
varios aplazamientos este 25 de
diciembre la avanzada tecnología busca
responder a preguntas sobre el origen de
la vida y establecer si estamos solos o
no en el universo
andrés granadillo nos amplía
entender el universo y nuestro lugar en
el es la misión del telescopio espacial
james webb diseñado para observar más
lejos que nunca me gusta pensar en él
como el vehículo de la nasa para la
exploración espacial más profunda que la
nasa puede hacer nos permitirá ver más
atrás en el tiempo hasta el momento en
que nacieron las primeras estrellas
sobre la acción 6 el telescopio
bautizado así en honor al ex director de
la nasa será llevado al espacio en el
cohete europeo ariane-5 que lo liberará
tras un viaje de 26 minutos al mirar en
el infrarrojo el telescopio podrá ver
moléculas alrededor de estrellas jóvenes
que aún se están formando también
podremos ver atmósferas de planetas
alrededor de otras estrellas
observaremos cientos de ellas y podremos
ver moléculas basadas en carbono que son
importantes para la vida y también
indican la química y sólo la composición
general de estas atmósferas que no
conocemos ahora originalmente el
telescopio debía estar en el espacio
hace más de una década pero su
lanzamiento ha sufrido innumerables
retrasos la pandemia y problemas
técnicos causaron que no pudiera ponerse
en órbita hace siete meses más siente
fue debido al mal tiempo en el sitio de
lanzamiento en la guyana francesa
finalmente despega esta navidad para
responder preguntas como cómo llegamos
hasta aquí que tan único es nuestro
planeta y estamos solos en el universo
hasta aquí nuestra emisión de noticias
pero ustedes sigan conectados a la señal
de 24 horas de france 24 y consulten
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
[Música]